so you like legacy titles from
playstation huh well i've got some good
news for you we're also going to talk
about bad santa football and more
playstation is reportedly planning a new
subscription service to compete with
xbox game pass with the ability to play
original playstation 1 2 3 and psp games
on most likely the playstation 4 and 5.
according to bloomberg this service is
codenamed spartacus and is reportedly
expected to launch in spring 2022 and it
will merge both existing subscription
plans of playstation plus and
playstation now together however the
playstation now name is going to be
phased out while playstation plus
remains
details aren't finalized but the service
will reportedly have three tiers the
first tier will retain existing
playstation plus benefits and the second
tier will allow players to access a
large selection of playstation 4 titles
and ps5 ones eventually
the third and highest tier will include
extended demos game streaming and a
library of legacy content from the
consoles i named earlier
vita games seem to be absent from the
lineup although it's possible that's due
to the difficulty of mapping touch
controls to a ps4 or ps5 controller
in other playstation news a spokesperson
for godfall developer counter play has
reacted to some of this week's backlash
if you didn't know december's
playstation plus games were confirmed
earlier this week and included is a new
version of godfall called the challenger
edition that strips away the base game
and allows players to only engage with
the end game content this confused a lot
of playstation plus members who quickly
took to social media to label the game a
demo of sorts in response the devs
spokesperson told eurogamer the
challenger edition is quote not a trial
short and sweet
just like the challenger edition i guess
moving on to some battlefield news on
twitter dice announced that battlefield
2042's least holiday santa claus
specialist skin will not be available
the developer explained that the skins
were developed as options but quote we
presently have no plans to utilize all
of them this holiday and although murder
clause won't be making his way into 2042
dice did promise opportunities to obtain
other skins starting the week of
december 6 players can complete
objectives to earn new skins and new
items every week there will be a new
skin to unlock until season 1.
and sticking with electronic arts titles
ea sports has confirmed that it will
continue to update and support madden
nfl 2022's franchise mode following
reports that suggested the developer
would not release any further updates
for it in a statement to ign a
spokesperson for ea sports said quote we
do not like to comment on rumors or
speculation however we are committed to
continuing to improve franchise as part
of our ongoing madden nfl 2022 live
service and beyond they continued quote
this includes two upcoming franchise
updates that we'll deliver in mountain
nfl 22. we will have more details on the
updates in the new year
so now hit the comment section let me
know what you're playing this weekend i
am hopelessly addicted to rocket league
sideswipe so let me know if you want to
1v1 me
i'll see you next week
[Music]
you